[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
دموع
دي مش جمله اتقالت في الفيلم بتاعنا
النهارده بس دي الحقيقه اللي هتفهمها في
نهايته واللي بطله الاحداث ما فهمتهاش الا
بعد فوات الاوان هو الطموح بيوصلنا لحد
فين للنجاح ممكن للفشل ليه لا بس هل
الطموح ممكن يوصلنا للجنون خصوصا لو
الطموح ده مصحوب برغبه شديده في المثاليه
والكمال واي درجه من الجنون هتوصل لها لو
كل العوامل دي مصحوبه بضغط شديد جدا من
اللي حوالينا ومن نفسنا وافكارنا النهارده
اسمحلي اخدك في رحله لمباراه واحد من اروع
افلام المخرج دايرن ارانوس واللي فازت
بطلته بجائزه الاوسكار عن افضل الاباء انا
محمود النجار والنهارده هنروح سوا لما
وراء فيلم
في البدايه اعرفك ببطله الملحمه اللي
هنتكلم عنها النهارده مينا والعمل الدورها
باداء رائع خاطف للانفاس الممثله نتالي
مينا بتشتغل بلارينا دانس وبتستعد في
التدريب لاداء الدور الرئيسي في العرض
الاشهر
وعلشان اقدر ادخل معاك في احداث الفيلم
بعمق محتاجين نبدا الاول باسمه ليه اتسمى
ليه ما سماش مثلا باليرينا او سوان ليج او
حتى
بمنتهى البساطه
بتاع البلاكس وان هي في نظر نينا قمه
النجاح ولعب دورها في العرض هو الكمال
بعينه وعلشان هي بلارينا شاطره جدا مثاليه
في كل حركه بتاديها بس هي اقرب لدور
الوايتسوان عن وده ملخص بسيط منه اقدر
ابدا معك الفيلم باريحيه بدايه الفيلم
حقيقي فيها عبقريه عبقريه مش هتفهمها غير
لما تشوف الفيلم للمره التانيه لان في
تتحيته بدات بحلم لينا اللي حلمت فيه
بافتتاحيه بحيره البجعه لما الساحر القت
عودته على الاميره الحلم ده كان غرضه يوصل
للمشاهد مجموعه رسايل ان الفيلم هيكون فيه
لمسه سيرياليه واضحه هتستمر معك للنهايه
انه هيكون رؤيه مختلفه ولكن على نفس نهج
بحيره المجعه ان مينا بطلتنا واقعه تحت
تاثير صراعها الداخلي اللي معبر عنه في
الحلم بالتعويزه بيوضح لك المخرج ملامح
شخصيه نينا من علامات بسيطه زي اوضتها
اللي بلون زهري والدتها اللي لسه عايشه
معاها وهي في سن 27 واللي بيدل على فرض
سيطره ولادتها عليها ومعاملتها كانها لسه
طفله صغيره تفتكر كابتن زي ده ممكن يوصل
بطلتنا لايه ده مكنش نوع الضغط الوحيد
اللي بتتعرض له في خلال التمارين بتتعرف
على ليليه البنت المرحه العشوائيه الملفته
للنظر الجريئه النقيض المثال النينا واللي
وجودها كان بيحسس لينا بالتهديد لانها من
جواها عارفه انها مثاليه لدور البجعه
الصودا اكتر منها هي شخصيا بجانب ضغط مدير
الفرقه بتاعها توماس شخص نرجسي سادي ما
بيحترمش غير الموهبه ومش شايف فينينا غير
شخص شكله حلو ينفع واجهه اعلاميه للفرقه
بالرغم من موهبتها وشغلها على نفسها بشكل
مبالغ فيه وده اللي بيوضحه المخرج في
لقطات هي بتعاني فيها من الغثيان والقيء
وردود افعال نينا بتوريك مع كل العوامل دي
قد ايه هي شخص سلبي تجاه الاحداث اللي
بتحصل حواليها وكمان ضعيفه الشخصيه ازاي
حد بملامح الشخصيه دي ممكن يلعب دور البجع
الشريره الواثقه المغروره في واحد من اقوى
المشاهد الحوريه ما بين نينا وتوماس بيقول
لها
[موسيقى]
انه لما بيبص لها كل اللي بيشوفه هو
البجعه البيضاء هي جميله خايفه هشه
ومثاليه بس البجعه السوداء
لا مش شايفها في الدور ده بيكمل كلامه
وبيقول
[موسيقى]
براين
انا في خلال الاربع سنين اللي شفتك فيهم
بترقصي بشوفك بتادي كل حركه وكل خطوه
مزبوطه وصح الصح بس عمري ما شفتك بترقصي
بانسيابيه من غير تفكير ولما بتفهمه انها
عايزه توصل للكمال رد عليها بكود خرافيه
وقال لها
[موسيقى]
هتعمل ده فعلا هل هتبقى
نشوف الاحداث بنفسك خلينا بقى نبعد عن
الاحداث شويه وندخل في جزئيه بحب اللعبه
بيها قوي وهي الادوات المتاحه مع المخرج
ولان افلام ما بتخلاش من اللعب على العامل
النفسي زي الفيلم الايقونه بتاعه بس ده
هنتكلم عليه في وقت تاني كان ادواته هي
الوسيله اللي استخدمها علشان يوصل للمشاهد
البطله حاسه بايه بنلاقي استخدام قوي جدا
للمرايات في الفيلم واللي بيدي احياءات
بازدواجيه نينا خصوصا ان الجانب المتطرف
من شخصيتها كانت بتشوفه في المرايه وفي
انعكاساتها حتى في المترو كمان استخدام
المرايه كان في بعض المشاهد علشان يزيد من
التوتر في المشاهد اللي فيها لحظات مرعبه
تاني حاجه بنلاحظها هو استخدام الاضاءات
والتصوير بشكل مترابط علشان ينقل لك
التحول النفسي اللي نينا بتمر به من
الوايتس وان للبلاكس وان لحد ما يوصلك في
الاخر للماستر سين في الفيلم وهو وقت
العرض وحقيقي ده كان من اكتر المشاهد
المتعوبه عليه في التصوير خصوصا بتصليط
الضوء
وده تم باستخدام الاضاءه الاماميه اما بقى
الخيال المزدوج انه بيدعم فكره الازدواجيه
اللي في الفيلم اللي بدا بها وازاي مينا
بتفهم نفسها في الاخر علشان تقدر تجسد
البلع السوداء والبجعه البيضاء جسديا
العلاقه ما بين
خصوصا والصوت جزء لا يتجزا من تاثير اداء
نينا على صورتها الذاتيه والجمهور مع قرب
النهايه بتبدا ايدين مينا في تكوين قشر
وريش بيكبر بالتدريج مع كل لفه بتلفها لحد
ما بتكون اجنحه كامله المشهد ده تم
باستخدام تقنيه نظرا لان صعب جدا تنفيذ
التاثير ده باستخدام المكياج او الاطراف
الصناعيه اما بقى الصوت فكان ليه عامل
كبير جدا في نجاح المشهد واللي استخدمه
فيه خاصيه الديابيرك ساوند او الصوت
الحقيقي الصوت رفرفه الاجنحه اللي كان صوت
حصري للمشاهد والمينا واللي زود من احساس
واقعيه وجود الاجنحه تم من خلال خاصيه ومع
ذلك باستخدام لقطه عكسيه اللي بتوضح وجهه
نظر الجمهور بنلاقي ان ما فيش وجود
للاجنحه دي من الاساس التجربه السينمائيه
دي ومن خلال دمج كل الادوات من تقنيات
الصوت والصوره وكادرات خلت المشاهد يشوف
العرض من وجهه نظر المتفرجين في الصاله
وكمان من وجهه نظر نينا مشهد حقيقي في
مضمونه وقوي جدا
ان في حين ان كل جمهور شايف انه مجرد عرض
رسمي الا انه بالنسبه لنا التحول الكامل
للمثاليه والوصول لاعلى درجات النجاح وان
هي على الرغم من كل الخسائر اللي خسرتها
في التحول ده هي البلاك وبيختم تحفته
الفنيه مع اكثر نهايه مفتوحه موتره ولكن
في نفس الوقت مثاليه مثاليه كانهايه لعرض
مبهر زي ده ومثاليه كنهايه لصراع النينا
النهايه بتبدا في ايدك انت كمشاهد هتقفلها
ازاي
تجربه سينمائيه دسمه وغنيه لو لسه ما
اتفرجتش عليها انصحك ما تفوتهاش وهستناك
الاسبوع اللي جاي في فيلم جديد
الافلام المقدم للعربيه
[موسيقى]